they're heading you stationary points
and points of inflection this is the
time to learn this now sir I'm going to
get another piece of it up rattling this
is the types of learners now because you
now know what these things are and you
don't find them in you know it first
executive you and all that company okay
so we're going to go through them one
step at a time the first page the one
with the heading on it is stationary
points if you're right up the earth this
is for stationary points everything
we're about to say all the steps and
thought processes that I'm going to
explain they all have to do with
stationary woods okay now you guys can
help me with a lot of this it took a
huge amount ok what's the very first
thing you need to do you get given a
function y equals you do this cube got a
little life you would find station in
points there's a first step you have to
do before anything can happen what is
the deep yeah you should differentiate
find the first riddle ok so let's write
that down that is the first step right
here find dy and DX you can't do
anything until you have the first three
minute ok now from there once you've got
the first derivative there's something
that you're looking for your kind of
looking for two things and again this is
kind of what we're talking about last
lesson you're looking for places where
that first derivative either is zero or
whether it doesn't exist ok those are
both important to us so we would call
those the places where the first
derivative is zero we call them zeros or
places where the first derivative does
in India's will call them
discontinuities in the derivative ok
please note that i don't mean
discontinuities in the graph itself if
the graph itself is discontinuous i know
there might be a stationary points there
because the graph is not there so
there's no point so you can't have a
stationary point so what we're looking
for are zeros or discontinuities ? ok
now for in many cases there will not be
any zeros or discontinuities for example
when we get to exponential functions I
cannot an exponential function looks
like it goes this
okay and even though you don't know yet
how to differentiate if you can know
this never going to turn okay and has
those bricks in it okay so therefore it
doesn't have zeros or just produce so if
there are none right then there are no
stationary points full stop and go
that's nice okay that happens in fact
sometimes the question will say you know
prove that such and such a function has
those stationary points and what you're
doing is finding the derivative showing
that whatever function it is the
derivative has those zeros of
discontinuities therefore I'm done of
course that is not what usually happens
in these kinds of questions usually we
expecting yes there will be a 0 or
discontinuity or several of them at
which point now we have a choice you
guys now know there are two ways to
after this box up here which is locate
the stationary points we need to
determine nature now right and we have
two methods for this what was the first
method I showed you the table values for
the first derivative so over here on the
left i'm going to call this the first
derivative dy on DX table of values okay
now before we look at the alternative
method which you we were looking at just
recently um if you do to the tailor
those which you will do it many times
there will be one of three outcomes that
will happen out of that once you have a
look at you know this value this value
is over you what are the three possible
things you could get after you do the
table you can get here you could get a
maximum or you could get a horizontal
point of inflection don't forget all of
this is after I've gotten beyond as you
read for the first video so not just a
regular point of flexion it's a
horizontal one so straight out of table
values you just reoffer you'll only get
a maximum or a min of them or are
horizontal point of inflection and
you'll read that bus use off of the
signs of the first derivative on the
left and the right okay you happy with
that so that's the first part but we
have learned with the second derivative
what's the second returns back from
cavity we can take that as a way to
determine the nature of this stationary
point right so instead of the first
iridium over here i'm choosing my second
option we look at the second derivative
okay and what we're going to do is we're
going to use the second area to check
concavity right check is a concave up or
is it concave down okay now concave up
concave down what that corresponds to is
the second derivative added sign okay so
if the second derivative is negative you
know what's going to happen if the
second derivative is positive you know
what's going to happen in other words so
long as the second derivative is not
zero if it's a positive or a negative
number then you know exactly what's
going to happen I do you have a maximum
or you have minimum right so in some
ways I've used that test I found Oh
concave up that's a minimum or
alternatively concave down that that
happens when the secondary this is a
number that's nonzero okay that's great
and then you're at the end of the line
alternatively know the second derivative
can be 0 we've seen examples of this
right so if the second derivative is 0
now we have another question to ask
right what you might this point be I've
already found the first term in 20 and
now I've found the second derivative is
0 what could it be what possible things
do I have let me give you clue I know
it's not a maximum it would be it could
be a horizontal plane inflection right
maybe but I don't actually know do I cuz
what was the example we looked at this
morning we looked at X to the power of 4
like that quartet now at that point
we've gotten a zero for the first degree
I've got this 0 0 for the second
derivative but it's it's not that
actually isn't a horizontal point in
flexion so I don't do it I can't just
conclude oh cool go through this is zero
I'm done in fact at this point to really
show it's a point in flexion I have to
say more than just tell me the concavity
I have to do a table of knowledge but
for the second derivative okay now i
have taught it to the left after vote to
write and i have to see what's going on
okay now if indeed there is a change in
concavity we're all good everything's
fine I have a point of inflection graba
cycles I just felt really antisocial and
then I could ok sorry I was mid-sentence
if i do the table values and I find like
I really want there is a change in
concavity right my second derivative
goes from negative to positive or
positive to negative and that's great
I've got a point of inflection and
because I already know the first
derivative is zero it's flat right there
were two horizontal point infection but
of course it might not change in
concavity right and we were just looking
at that extra for example if there is no
change I've got bad news for you buddy
you have to go back to the first
derivative right because if there's no
change in concavity you know it's a
stationary point and you know it's not a
horizontal point collection it could
still be either a max or min and the
second Riveter doesn't tell you you must
result back to the first through to find
out what's going to left what's going on
the right and then you can make a
conclusion about whether to max for you
know okay so even though it's like hey
cool i don't have to do the table values
anymore if there's a special enough case
you're going to get the longest possible
paths through here is derivative 0
second derivative second t20 god dude my
table values and then there's no change
and then i do another table values is
sometimes that will happen now here's
the thing right be smart about it ok you
get soon twice's so if you see y equals
x to the 4 an example that I was
specifically
shown you then don't check beacon cavity
using the second derivative right it's
not going to help you determine the need
for that stationary way you should
recognize it you should say forget it
this is there going to be no use to me
I'm going to go straight to the tale of
those for the first room it's not the
quickest but you don't have a choice to
avoid it you have to do that for such a
choice okay does that make sense a
questions so there you go that's
stationary points let's turn